SPEAKER: Good
afternoon, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
SPEAKER: Happy pride.
AUDIENCE: Happy pride.
[CHEERING]
SPEAKER: So a big welcome
to everybody in Dublin
and to everybody watching
on livestream in EMEA.
2016, is it really that easy to
bring your whole self to work?
Have you ever received
a few average grades
at university or
failed something,
and you've overanalyzed
it time and time again
wondering what went wrong?
Have you ever gone to
school in the morning
and put your head down and not
wanted anyone to look at you?
Have you ever gotten a new
haircut and it's gone a bit
lopsided or it looks
a bit different,
and you know everybody's
watching you,
and you wish they'd stop?
So Google Dublin
for this year is
trying to set the gold standard
for culture and inclusion.
So I'm very delighted that
we have an external speaker
with us today, Ailbhe Smyth.
Smyth is an activist
and former academic
who has been involved in
feminist, LGBT, and radical
politics for a long time.
She set up the Women's Education
Research and Resource Centre,
and was head of
Women's Studies at UCD,
which is the university in
Dublin, from 1990 until 2006,
when she left the university
to work independently, mainly
with community women's
groups and organizations.
Ailbhe has lectured
and written extensively
about feminism, women,
politics, and culture
in contemporary Ireland.
She's a founding member of
the organization, Marriage
Equality, and she was
centrally involved
in the victorious Yes Equality
referendum campaign in 2015.
Please put your hands
together and welcome
Ailbhe Smith on stage.
[APPLAUSE]
AILBHE SMYTH: Thank you.
Thank you very much, Adam,
for that lovely introduction.
And hello everybody.
It is such a treat
to be here in Google.
And perhaps I'll take
my jacket off, actually.
A little bit of strip
at the beginning
is always a good idea, I think.
You get down to
the real business.
Is it really that easy to
bring your whole self to work?
I looked at this when Adam sent
me a really very clear e-mail.
And I thought, I
really don't think
I can do this with
Google because there
is a whole experience, there
is a whole world of change,
if you like, that separates
your work experiences and mine.
There's generations
of change there.
And I thought, hmm, maybe
I'll go to the second time
and see what it says under that.
Take the scarf off?
Right, OK.
What next?
[LAUGHTER]
Well, Gayglers are well
used to this kind of thing.
And then the next line was,
how we cope with or bounce back
from or keep going in adversity.
And I thought, adversity.
I know all about
adversity, absolutely.
So I don't have a grand theory.
I don't have expert solutions.
I don't have a recipe.
I don't even have tips
on how you bounce back
or stay resilient or whatever.
All I can tell you is
that a couple weeks ago,
as Andrew will confirm,
I celebrated a really big
birthday.
I really don't want to have to
say it, but my 70th birthday.
And I'm still here.
And I'm still going strong.
So something must be working
somewhere along the line.
And in a way, I thought maybe
the most honest and true thing
that I could do with
you today is really
tell you a little bit about
what has gone on in my life,
not only in relation
to work because I think
maybe the first thing I
would say about bringing
our whole selves into
work is that you have
to be in touch with
who your self is
and have quite a clear idea
about what parts of your self
might not be fitting
in here out there.
Whether you bring and what you
bring into the workplace also,
therefore, depends a lot on
you, a lot on your context--
your social context,
your political context,
your geographical context.
But also, it depends hugely on
the nature of your workplace.
And it's my
impression-- obviously,
I've never worked here.
But it is my impression that
Google is the kind of place
that you can bring far more
of yourself into than probably
most of the places
I've ever worked in
and probably most of the
places that the majority
of people in the world
actually still work in.
And I think that that's really
a very, very important point.
But before I go on
to talk personally,
I do want to say, echoing Adam's
words, something really very
important.
And that is to say happy
pride to everybody here
and to everybody in Google
whether you're L, G, B, T, I,
Q, R, A, I gather--
allies-- whatever you are,
and to say that I love
pride, that I think
pride is incredibly important.
I think it's
important politically.
I think to make a point that
life is not OK for LGBTQIs
here, or across the
world, even more.
Everything is not
won because we did
win that wonderful, glorious
marriage equality victory.
Everything is not
resolved by that.
But I also think that it's
really important socially
and for our communities.
And I say communities
because I do
think that LGBTIQ communities
are several, that we interlink,
that we interweave.
But we're not necessarily all
absolutely the same thing.
And I constantly
bear that in mind,
that there are many, many
differences between us.
But I do think it's important
for community, and not least
because that sense of community
and the importance of community
is something which I think
is becoming increasingly
difficult to maintain in the
material and physical world
in the 2000s.
And it seems to me
that that's something
that we do very, very well
through our pride celebrations,
not just in Ireland, but
throughout the world.
So I think it's
absolutely true that when
I march with all the wonderful,
the beautiful, the brave,
the excellent, the
funny, the clever people
who also march in pride,
and whatever their sexuality
and however they define or we
define our sexuality, I do.
I just burst with pride when I
think of all of the challenges
and the difficulties
and the obstacles
and the plain downright
horrible, damaging homophobia
that so many of us
have faced and go
on facing in some instances
in our lives, some people,
much more so than others.
But there is hardly--
and certainly
in my generation and the
generation after me, there
is not an LGBTIQ life that is
unscathed by that homophobia.
None of us have
got off scot free.
I've never yet met
somebody, LGBT,
et cetera, who has said to
me, oh, of my generation
and certainly the
one after me, and I
do believe right down or
up or across or however it
is you talk about
generations, there
is no life that hasn't
been touched in some way
and in many ways shaped
and really framed
by that homophobia.
And just to remind
myself as much as anybody
else here that homophobia
is quite simply
a dislike, a hatred of
people who are lesbian
or gay or bisexual or
transgender or intersex
or queer, and that even to say
that to yourself, even for me
to say that to myself,
gives me a shock every time
I think of it,
every time I see it.
Why?
Because I feel it in my body.
And I feel it in my bones.
And however brave and however
determined and however much fun
we have and however much
whatever, to have that frisson,
to have that shake
in your bones,
to have that little
feeling in your flesh
still there, that
there are people
who don't like people like you,
people like me, people like us,
to feel that whether it's
in relation to our sexuality
or any other aspect
of ourselves--
our ethnicity, our
social class, whether we
have a disability,
whatever it is-- that is
a deeply disempowering thing.
So it is incredibly
important for us,
I think, in a way
to recognize it
and to overcome that and
deal with it because I don't
know about you, but my vision
or my dream for a world--
and I say this as a feminist as
much as an LGBT activist-- is
a world where gender doesn't
matter anymore, where gender
doesn't determine in any way
the shape of your life, where
gender is not a factor that
is in any way allowed to get
into your bones and
shape you and make you,
where gender is simply neutral.
And that doesn't mean, by the
way, that we don't have sex.
That has absolutely
nothing to do with sex.
So let's get that point very
clear in our heads as well.
A world where gender is
not socially determining
is the world I would dream of.
And are we there yet,
as they say in the ad?
No, absolutely not.
Maybe a bit closer
here in this country.
in some countries.
But in many cases, not at all.
But when I say I burst with
pride, marching in pride,
there's also a part
of me-- and it's maybe
the contrary part of
me-- that's saying
I'm not quite sure the
"proud" is the right word
to use to describe or to define
how I feel about being lesbian.
I came out late.
Well, I mean, I think
that nowadays, it would
be considered rather late.
I was in my 30s, although
back then, way back then,
it wasn't all that bizarre.
I grew up without ever
hearing the word "lesbian."
I didn't even get
the word "gay."
I mean, there was Hilton Edwards
and the whole Michael Mac
Liammóir, who were two
theatrical personages.
And we knew that
they were a couple.
But nobody ever said
to me, oh, they're gay.
And nobody ever
said to me, well,
do you see that woman there?
She's lesbian.
I just had never heard them.
We didn't have the internet
obviously, the media.
I grew up in a world which
was definitionally, absolutely
dead straight.
A lot of it was pretty dead.
But it was really,
really, really, really,
really straight.
So when I did come out-- as I
say, rather late, in my 30s--
even though I knew-- I
knew that in my bones
already that it wasn't
going to be a picnic being
lesbian in Ireland at the time.
I was still absolutely thrilled
to discover that I was lesbian.
And I have to tell you, I
am still totally thrilled
by the fact that I'm lesbian.
So it's not about being proud.
I didn't do anything.
I didn't achieve anything
in order to be lesbian.
It's not something that I
deserve merit for or applause
or anything.
I just am lesbian.
And I absolutely love it.
And I love girls!
I love women!
And that's it!
[APPLAUSE]
But I am at the same
time very proud to be
part of a set of
communities, if you like,
where we have fought so
hard so that people like me
and people like you can
stand up and say, oh,
isn't it great to be gay?
Isn't it fantastic to be bi?
Isn't it just brilliant
to be lesbian?
Frankly, I think
that's the best of all.
But there you go.
[LAUGHTER]
A world where it's not all that
easy to stand up and say I'm
trans or I'm intersex.
And that, I think,
is true in Ireland,
as much as it is right
across Europe insofar
as we have Europe anymore
at all after today.
And also, in North
America, in South America,
and so on and so forth.
So there are a lot
of difficulties.
But of course, although I say I
came out when I was in my 30s,
I didn't really come out
at all because I couldn't.
I couldn't.
There were people, also
lesbians, who knew.
And I knew.
And we went to more or less
the same sorts of places,
and we were friends.
But I couldn't come out
to most of my family.
Indeed, when I tried, it wasn't
that they pushed me away.
But the shutters came down.
They didn't want to hear.
They didn't want to know.
It was not part of
their vocabulary.
It wasn't part of
their picture of me
as a member of their family.
So for a long time, it was as
if you can imagine a family
photograph, where I was in
it, but with a black curtain
or something, yeah,
a big black curtain
pulled down over my face
so that I was in the family
but not as me, not the whole me.
And that's where the
whole self thing comes in
because that was something
that I struggled with for years
and years and years.
Eventually, most of my family
did actually come round.
And my parents, one
way and another,
were-- my father died
shortly after that.
But my mother was
reasonably supportive.
There are other
stories about that.
She used to-- when I
would bring girlfriends--
because I carried on as if
I was a proper, up front,
straight-up person,
member of this family.
So I would arrive
with the girlfriend.
And I would say,
here is Mary Jane,
or here is Patricia whatever.
And there was more
than one girlfriend,
as to you probably can
guess at this stage.
[LAUGHTER]
She would make an
instant decision.
And she used to offer the ones
she liked a glass of sherry,
which they never liked.
And she would offer all of
the others a cup of tea.
So that was her way of grading
her response to my lesbian
life.
So it was really
very interesting.
But I think my point is that
although I came out, really,
I couldn't actually
be out because they
wouldn't let me be out.
They didn't want me
to be the thing I was.
They liked what
they thought was me.
But they didn't
like that part of me
that was, at that stage,
very centrally me,
if that doesn't sound
too complicated.
And exactly that
kind of situation
was replicated in my
straight friendship circles,
where my social life just
completely went to the ground,
and where in work,
exactly the same.
Now, I worked in UCD, which
probably as a university
would have been considered
quite a liberal institution.
But it wasn't when
it came to sexuality.
And people told me
very specifically--
and I'm thinking back now
to the end of the '80s
and the beginning of the 1990s.
People told me, well,
OK, we've no problem
with you being lesbian.
That was lucky, wasn't it?
They had no problem
with who I was.
Think about the language there.
It's actually very condescending
and patronizing language.
But we don't advise
you to come out.
It wouldn't be a good
idea for promotion.
I was already a bad
I was a feminist.
I was a radical.
I was pro-choice.
I had left my husband after
six months of marriage
because it just
wasn't a good idea.
So I got out before
we got pinned down.
Why did I get married?
Because that was girls
of my middle class
did in this country at the time.
It didn't suit me at all.
But all of those things
were known about me,
that I was feminist,
and that I was radical,
and that I had left a marriage.
At that time, a lot
of you won't know,
there was no divorce in Ireland.
We didn't have divorce in
Ireland until 1995, I think.
Two referendums, in '95.
And of course, I was
pro-choice, which
has always been a very,
very subversive thing
to be in this country.
So at work, I was advised
not to say I was out
because it would affect
my promotional prospects,
whereas I knew perfectly well
that my promotional prospects
were already right down
the tubes quite a long time
before that.
So within a couple of years,
I thought, let's do this.
Let's actually all be out, all
of us who are lesbians in UCD,
and stop this absolute nonsense.
So at that stage,
I was heading up
the Center for Women's Studies.
And I thought, I
know what we'll do.
We'll have a day especially
for lesbians at the university
and see how they deal
with that little one.
So we did.
And we started
Lesbian Lives, which
is a conference-- and now a
two or three day conference--
that goes on every year.
So I think in that
instance, what
I was trying to do was
to say, I can't really
continue in this
environment unless I
am able to just simply
be all of myself.
And that part of
myself is a part
that I am not ashamed of,
that I am very pleased about.
But I can't do this on my own.
It's not just up to me.
There are other people here.
There are other
people out there who
need to be involved
and included in that.
And that was, in
a way, I suppose,
my response, but also my
challenge to the place that I
worked in, which was really
to put it up to them, to say,
we're going to have this
Lesbian Lives day on two days.
And yes, we will be here openly
in this precious environment
of the university.
And the wrath of God
or the president of UCD
did not fall on top of my head.
What did they do?
They just simply
continued to ignore.
It was as if it
had never happened.
Lesbian Lives happened
the next year, same thing.
It was as if that had
never, ever, ever happened.
And I realized then-- it
taught me a really, really
good lesson, that
sometimes you really
have to go right
up to them and say,
you have to take this on board.
You can't go on ignoring this
because if you have staff
who are lesbian and students
now who are lesbian,
think of all the others,
think of everyone else,
think of the future,
think of what
it is doing to your
university, our university
that you are in denial.
And that was a kind
of microcosm of what
was happening in this country as
a whole, I think, at the time.
I think that I was very lucky.
I'd had a few hard
knocks at that stage.
And as I say, I realized
that I wasn't exactly
on the fast track
to three chairs
and 60 million research grants,
although actually things
did come in the fullness
of time, I'm glad to say.
But I knew that I had
to go out and do that.
But I also knew I absolutely
couldn't do it on my own.
And as soon as I put the
call out, just a little
notice-- I think it was still at
the very early days of e-mail,
even.
Gosh, I'm so dinosauric,
when I think about it.
It was all done by hand
and little notice boards
and so on and so forth, asking
people to come to a meeting
about running a Lesbian
Lives conference.
Actually, women did come along.
It was quite extraordinary.
And I think that then
around about that time,
it was decided after Lesbian
Lives that there would
be a gay [? sock ?] in UCD.
And that actually happened.
But as I say, I had a little
bit of previous adversity.
There was the problem of
leaving my husband, which
really was a dreadful thing
to do in Ireland at the time.
And I had then gone on, as
one does, and met another guy,
who I really quite fancied.
And we decided to have
a baby, which we did.
But of course, I was still
married to somebody else.
And there was no divorce.
And that was a mortal sin.
So I was very marginalized
because of that.
And technically, my
daughter was considered
illegitimate and a bastard.
And that was also something
which had to be taken on.
Also, not entitled to my pension
in the event of my early death.
So always a material
girl, I actually
tackled that bit
first to make sure
that that could be changed.
So that regulation
was actually changed
for the whole of the
civil service, which
I thought was very important.
And then, eventually
illegitimacy
as a category actually was
taken out of our legal system.
And just a bit before
that, I had, I think,
really it happened for
all kinds of reasons.
But I had quite a
serious breakdown.
I got anorexia nervosa and had
quite a severe mental breakdown
and was in hospital
for six months.
And that, of course, was also
hugely, hugely stigmatized.
And I think we know that
mental illness is still very
stigmatized in this country.
And if nobody would
talk about the fact
that I was a feminist
and lesbian, certainly,
absolutely no one at all
ever referred to the fact
that I had had a breakdown.
And when I resumed
normal activities,
it was, again, as if absolutely
nothing had happened.
So I eventually got over that.
But you might be saying, well,
why am I telling you this?
Because I think there are a lot
of lives like mine actually.
And I think that what people go
through in our lives is often
very undercover, and
however open the environment
we work in, there
can be things that
are very difficult for
people to talk about.
So it is, I think,
certainly much easier,
much more-- Google is a very
open environment, certainly,
in respect of sexuality.
I don't know about other things.
I do know that there are other
working environments where it's
really difficult. People
will lose their jobs
if they have a breakdown.
They will lose their jobs
if there is a suspicion
that there's mental illness.
They may lose their job
still, although it would never
be said explicitly, if
they come out as gay,
and particularly, if
they come out as trans.
So I suppose I'm
saying that we have
to always look for the ways that
we can do more than survive.
And some of the ways
that I have found
are to be myself,
full stop, in a way,
to try always to be myself, with
all the complexity that that
involves, all the
bits and pieces.
We're never just gay.
We're never just lesbian,
like, we're never
just a woman or just a
man or just a whatever.
Our identities are so
complicated, aren't they?
I'm a mother.
I'm a granny.
And my daughter;s one
set of her in-laws,
was a little bit
shocked to think that
their daughter-in-law's
mother was a dyke.
I mean, not her
sister, but the mother.
Right.
OK?
So what was this
going to look like?
And then you do the
t-shirt bit and you say,
this is what a
lesbian looks like.
And they say things
to you like, oh,
but you're really very nice.
What did they expect?
What did they think
I was going to do?
Eat them up?
Devour them?
I don't know.
That's just those layers of
usually unspoken prejudice
and bias and fundamentally,
homophobia, fear and hatred
of lesbians and gays and
bisexuals and transpeople
that's still there.
But I have found
that it's wiser.
I don't know that it's easier.
I don't know if it's better.
It's just wiser in the long
run to be completely upfront
about who and what you
are, and preferably,
to find other people
roughly similar to yourself.
We're all different.
We're all unique.
We're all wonderful
and beautiful.
So find somebody and
somebody and somebody
as you do with the Gayglers,
who's roughly similar to you.
And take on the situation.
It doesn't have to
be in your face.
be confrontational.
It just has to be consistent
and firm and fair and visible
pretty well all the time.
I forgot something else.
I'm now actually beginning
to encounter a bit of ageism.
But nobody here has any
idea what I'm talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
So I won't actually
talk about that.
But let me just tell you
that sometimes, I think,
there's a sense in which
you feel oh, my god, there's
no end to what we
might encounter.
So you might say,
just to finish up,
have I learned anything that
might be of use to any of you?
I very much doubt that.
I think that we
create our worlds.
We really do.
I think that for people
under-- roughly speaking,
I'm not going to put a date,
roughly there in the middle.
OK?
About half way down from me.
Whatever.
It is a very different world.
But I do think that
bearing in mind
that people's lives--
first thing, I'd say,
people's lives are complicated.
Things can go up and down.
And whatever we do to
always bear that in mind.
Secondly, there are common
threads that unite us,
and to hold on to those threads
as much as we possibly can.
And the most important thing,
I think, well, the two most
important things are to speak
up, stand up for yourself,
and just keep at it.
Never give up.
Somebody asked me those 50
best pieces of advice podcast
thing the other day.
And somebody sent me an e-mail
and said, we want a photograph.
And we want your best advice.
And I suppose they thought
I'd write a paragraph.
I just put back, never
give up because actually, I
think that's really important.
Whatever it is you're at,
in your job, in your life,
everywhere, if it's
important to you,
if it really matters to you,
stick with it, stand up for it,
get other people to
help you, or work
with them to stand up for it.
Stick with it.
Don't give up.
Never give in.
Why would we ever give
in to those who would
have us do something else?
I'm sure you've found
this a bit meandering.
I hope it might have struck
a chord somewhere, somehow,
along the line.
It's been really a
pleasure to speak with you.
I'm sure you'd have great
practical questions about how
to survive in the workplace
to the wonderful panel who
are coming on now.
And I'll join the panel.
Thank you so much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, I have to sit down.
SPEAKER: So thank you
very much, Ailbhe.
Some very inspirational stories.
And I can't wait to hear more.
So guys, we're going to
a panel discussion now
and Q&A. So please welcome
Jennifer Kelly, who's
the vice-president of the Real
Estate and Workplace Services,
and Andrew Highland,
who's Community Relations
Manager for the Data Centers.
[APPLAUSE]
[WHISPERING]
So Jen, we might start
with you if you'd
like to share a few
of your reactions
to what Ailbhe has talked
about and your own thoughts.
JENNIFER KELLY: Sure,
I loved Ailbhe's talk.
Thank you so much.
I got a lot of laughs.
I got a lot of insights.
And what's great for me
and what struck a chord
with me is, I don't wake up
every day and say, oh, my god,
there's the alarm,
fantastic, because I
love that time of the day.
But I don't wake up and
say, oh, I'm a woman.
I'm a woman today.
I wake up every day.
And I'm just the same
as everybody else.
I get up and do all
the crazy things we all
have to do in the mornings.
And the day turns out
differently every day.
So obviously, I really feel that
I do come to work as myself.
I come to work as my whole self.
And I come to work
as my authentic self.
And I don't mask that.
I get up, and I bring my
daughter to school every day.
And I don't apologize for that.
That's an important time.
That's really important to me.
And where my first
tough part of the day
is when, some of the other
moms at the gate say,
would you like to
go to a spin class?
We're going to
Insomnia for coffee.
And they'll ask several people.
And then they're just
like, you're going to work.
Right?
So it's straight off, yes I am.
And I feel great that
I'm going to work.
But there's this little
judgment right there.
And if I wasn't going
to work, I wouldn't
be going to spin class.
I just want to put that
out there straightaway.
Because when I go home,
I say to my husband,
they're all off
to the spin class.
And he gives me the, if you
were off, you wouldn't be going.
So let's just start with that.
And then I drive through
the Phoenix Park.
And I see all these people out
jogging and pushing the kids.
And then I have other
little bit of guilt.
And then I just get over it.
And I go to work.
But that, for me,
is the biggest part,
and probably why after
12 years, I still
love getting up and
going to work at Google
is I feel that is authentic.
I come to work as me.
And I don't have to make any
allowances or apologies for who
I am when I come to work.
SPEAKER: I suppose
for me, myself,
and the world-- I lead
the Gayglers for Dublin.
And I come across people who
are afraid to come out at work
and not be themselves because
they feel that, depending
on their own
circumstances, where they
grew up, or for a
different environments
that they grew up in, they don't
feel confident in doing that.
But I suppose when you
think about coming out,
it's a difficult conversation.
So would you have any
difficult conversation
that you've had in your
life that you could share.
JENNIFER KELLY: Yes.
Specific to work,
I've had conversations
and I've sat on--
a few times when
we've had career weeks
and career panels,
and people have said, where
did you go to college?
What did you do?
What qualified you
to come to Google?
And people have been
quite reactionary
when I've said to them,
I didn't go to college.
I don't have a degree.
And people have looked at
me, shocked, first of all,
or have said, how
did you get hired?
And they've said it
not in a hurtful way.
It was just in a
complete shock way.
And after they've said it,
I've thought, oh, my god, I
shouldn't have said that.
I said, I just
guess I was awesome.
I don't know.
I interviewed.
I did 5,000 interviews
back in the day,
12 years ago, like
everybody else did.
But I came to Google with a lot
of experience doing what I did,
and that was part of, I
guess, why I was hired.
And I get from a culture
perspective, I was a fit.
But that has come
up numerous times.
And people have even said, we'd
like you to sit on the panel
and say this.
It's almost you feel like
that's a judgment in itself,
that OK, let's put four
people on that have degrees.
And then let's get
Jen because she's
the only one we know at Google.
There might be other
people out there.
We could set up a little group.
And I'm proud that I'm
here today having not gone
through the same process.
But at the time, it
wasn't an option for me.
When I left school, I needed to
get a job straightaway and be
somewhat self-sufficient.
And I did.
And I think that
has probably made
me feel prouder
about who I am today
and what I've achieved today.
AILBHE SMYTH: Woo-hoo,
is what I say.
ANDREW HIGHLAND: Can I
come in there as well?
SPEAKER: Andrew.
ANDREW HIGHLAND: I've
never had to come out
at work because I've really
been reflecting on this
since you asked me
to be on the panel.
I've been lucky in that
sense that I've never
had to come out.
But I have had to
be in conversations
where, in order for a
client to know that I'm gay,
I've gone, oh, I'm going
home to my boyfriend,
or something like that.
But similar to
Ailbhe's experience,
I have had that, oh, my god.
You're gay.
Oh, I never thought
you were gay.
You know?
What was one comment.
Yeah, you're not
stereotypical, really, are you?
So that was deep.
And sometimes, I had to bury it.
I had to bury my
activist self down
because I wanted to tell them
that that was quite offensive
and the comments
weren't always welcome.
But because they
were a client, I
had to go, oh, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: And Andrew, you might
elaborate a bit more on that.
So what does that mean for
you to bring your whole self
to work every day at Google?
ANDREW HIGHLAND:
Yeah, first thing
I want to say because
when Adam said it earlier,
you were all a bit lame.
So I think when we
say happy pride,
you all need to
scream happy pride,
because pride is about
protest and celebration.
So happy pride, everybody!
AUDIENCE: Happy pride!
ANDREW HIGHLAND: That's
much better, much better.
Pride, for me-- or excuse
me, bringing my whole self
to work for me, and especially
since I've been in Google
and experiencing Gayglers
for the first time in terms
of a group for gay
people, LGBT people,
I think it's
absolutely marvelous.
I reflected on
things like Orlando
and what happened there.
I've been reflecting on what's
happening in the Middle East
and gay men being thrown off
buildings to certain death.
And the fact that in
certain countries,
it's not just about being
OK to be gay or anything
else, that people are dying.
And I think we have to realize
how privileged and lucky
we are to live and
work in a country
that not only accepts us.
It's not about tolerance,
as you were saying earlier.
It's about inclusivity.
And I think it's brilliant
that so many people are here
to share this today.
But I think when I was
thinking about it, as well,
there's some
comparisons to-- I did
a masters as a mature student
at UCD in equality studies.
So you think, equality studies.
Everybody's down with the gays.
And I realized that
people weren't.
They thought there's a level of
equality that we should have.
So I remember one Irish guy was
very against marriage equality.
And I found that very difficult.
But there was one woman,
she was from central Africa.
And when I was
reflecting on this,
similar to our
multi-continental,
multi-regional, multi-culture,
multi-religious, and
multi-sexuality company, the
masters was quite the same.
And this woman was essentially
incredibly homophobic,
based on social and
religious beliefs.
But she wanted to
learn about me.
And I decided, yeah,
this was going to be
my little project for the year.
So whenever she wanted
to ask me a question,
I would, yeah, go ahead and--
so we had this understanding
that I knew where she was
coming from and vice-versa.
By the end of the year,
she left in such a way
that she knew I
was a good person.
She knew I came
from a great family.
She knew I loved my family.
She knew I had a great
community of friends.
She knew I was a good person.
And all those things
that the beliefs
in her country, the belief
system, said different.
So I was just happy.
And I think we can
do the same here
in recognizing that we work
with a vast array of people.
And we shouldn't expect
that they will immediately
be OK with LGBT people.
They may have come from
an education system
where they were taught that
it's not OK to be LGBT.
So I think when we're bringing
our full selves to work,
as Ailbhe said,
it's about bringing
that honest self to work.
And if somebody does have
open and honest questions,
based on them trying to
change their narrative
and their beliefs, that you
give them that opportunity.
SPEAKER: And we
might bring that back
to Ailbhe as well because
you mentioned in your speech
about the use of condescending
language and the other person
who's speaking
might not understand
that they're actually
using language
that might be offensive.
For example, sometimes,
we'll have managers here
who have questions
and just not know
how to approach a
transgender issue
or not know how to
approach somebody
that might be LGBT on their
teams and how to help them.
So what kind of tips
or tools or framework
would you give them to try
and get them on the journey?
AILBHE SMYTH: Well, I think
the first step probably
is acknowledging that
none of us always
have the right language
for all kinds of situations
and that the best and most
honest thing one can do
is to ask a question,
to say, I'm not sure
how you define yourself.
Would you like to tell me?
And then pick up on that
and work from there.
And always say, in whatever
situation you're in-- I
don't know.
Jen, you'd have a lot of
experience in that too.
It's better to put
your hand up or to ask.
Better to say--
and never assume.
Actually, I think that's it.
It's not making assumptions
about who people are
and what they believe, which
picks up on several things
that Andrew was saying.
JENNIFER KELLY: And I think
that has changed a lot.
So Ailbhe, you talked about
your journey over time.
And there was a period
of time in Dublin
where you just did not
talk about anything
to do with sexuality.
AILBHE SMYTH: Absolutely,
you didn't talk about sex.
JENNIFER KELLY: Absolutely,
not in my house anyway,
you certainly didn't.
AILBHE SMYTH: No, no, never.
JENNIFER KELLY: I come
from a very big family.
I'm the youngest of eight.
My mother was born in 1924.
She raised all of us on
her own from the time
I was seven years old because
my father passed away.
And we had a very
Catholic household.
And you did not swear.
And you didn't say, oh, Jesus,
if you dropped something
or you got a crack.
And she was the
most loving mother.
But above all, she was very
Christian in her approach.
So she helped everybody.
She helped anybody.
It didn't matter who they were.
But of course, she had
come through an education
where you just didn't
talk about these things.
And she worked in
St. James's hospital
at night as a nurse's assistant.
She specialized
with hospital, which
was the HIV patients,
which there was
so many of through the '80s.
And she would work Thursday,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
And then I noticed she
was going in day time.
And she said, some
of them are very ill.
And they don't have anybody,
because at this stage,
their families did
not want to know.
They wanted to pretend
it wasn't happening.
So she'd be making
special dishes to bring in
because they couldn't eat.
She was with-- one of the
probably more public figures
was Vincent Hanley, who
was a radio personality.
And she was with him--
his family were too.
He was very supported-- until
he passed away because she just
bonded with people.
And to me, that told me a lot
about there's certain things.
And I'm not going to bring
it up at the kitchen table.
Right?
Because it just
wasn't the right time.
But also that she just
had such a good heart.
And I think that
that's what I learned.
Maybe there isn't
the right time.
You don't want to rock
the boat sometimes.
Or you didn't at the time.
And she's no longer
with us today.
But I feel if she was,
she'd be saying good on you.
Get up and go.
Because I'm going to go
to pride tomorrow and join
the team from here.
And my nine-year-old is coming.
And she is-- it's a hoot.
She can't wait to get out there.
And you will see her.
She's planned the whole outfit.
Everything is going on.
But I think it is
important to help people
along that journey
that have come
from a different
background, come
from a different upbringing,
a different religious belief,
because you just can't
expect everybody to be open
and on board the way
everybody else is.
AILBHE SMYTH: I feel at
this stage of my life--
my mother, who died very
recently, actually--
that if I and other
members of my family
brought her along on the road
to more or less accepting
multiple sexualities,
even in her own family,
we could do it with anyone.
I mean, I really do
actually feel this.
I remember years
and years and years
ago being on a radio
program on Sunday morning
about a discussion.
And one part of the discussion
was about discrimination
against gays at work.
So of course, I was
talking about this
and saying yes, it
happens to lesbians.
It happens to gays.
And that evening,
I got a phone call
from my mother, who had
her very, very, very
annoyed, disapproving voice.
So I knew there was
something wrong.
I said, what's wrong, Mom?
And she said, no, it's just
I'm having big problems.
She said, it was that
program this morning.
So I said, oh, dear,
yes, right. what was it?
It's that bedroom language!
And on a Sunday!
[LAUGHTER]
But it was very revealing
because her whole understanding
of what it meant to be
lesbian or gay or bi or trans
or whatever it was--
oh, it's about sex.
And it taught me a really,
really, really important lesson
or revealed something
really important,
apart from annoying me
like mad, you can imagine.
SPEAKER: And just one last
question maybe for you, Jen.
as VP of [INAUDIBLE] you're
also the exec sponsor
for the Gayglers in Dublin.
JENNIFER KELLY: I am.
SPEAKER: So why that
you want to take
on that role in the first place?
JENNIFER KELLY: So
it's a group at Google
that I've always been
very interested in,
worked closely in Dubleads
alongside Gareth Morgan, who
was the exec sponsor last year.
And I thought that it's
an amazing group that's
achieving a lot and has
a lot of outreach across,
not only Dublin, but all
of our sites globally.
And being part of
the [INAUDIBLE] team,
our mission is to provide work
spaces and work environments
where people can come every
day and be at their best.
And that's not just about having
a great gym and fantastic food,
which you have to have both,
because the food is so good,
you have to have the gym.
But for me, it's about
creating an environment where
you can come and be
productive and work,
but you can be yourself.
And so most of what we do
in the spaces we provide,
it really links into just
how people feel at work.
So I thought, I would
love to get an inside
and work closely with the group
so I can bring the two together
and try to help, and not
only with creating programs
and supporting the programs that
Adam and the rest of the team
need, but wouldn't it be
great if we can actually
link the space and how
we think about the space.
And I will say that I've
gone through these sessions
with Adam where I'm like,
what does that mean?
Can I say that?
Is that word OK?
LGBT, can you say the the Q?
And what the hell is the I?
So what am I?
And he's been amazing.
And also, he's taken me through
the Trans 101 training, which
is really, really informative.
And that's been a whole
new learning for me
because I want to be able,
in my [INAUDIBLE] role
and in my Google leader role,
to be able to support everybody.
Now, that doesn't mean as
people come to me and ask me
a question, I'll be like, now,
what do you-- what do you--
It doesn't matter.
I just want to have
the insights into what
makes people happy,
because if you're happy,
you're going to feel safe, and
you're going to be productive.
And I think the biggest
thing-- happy is great.
Productive is great.
The more important
thing to me is
people feel safe, and not just
physically, security-wise safe,
but just safe in themselves.
I don't send my child to
work every day and say--
or to school.
She's not working yet.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: The truth is out.
JENNIFER KELLY: The truth.
But I don't send her
to school and say,
I hope she's really
productive today.
And I hope she's really happy.
But safety is the one thing
I worry about every day.
And I want to bring
that to work too,
because that's very important.
You won't be happy or productive
if you don't feel safe.
AILBHE SMYTH: So true.
SPEAKER: Thanks very
much, everybody.
So we'll take questions
now from the audience.
Anyone want to start?
We'll throw the microphone.
Thanks, Anna.
Someone at the back.
JENNIFER KELLY: Oh, it's
no an Android anymore.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
Can-- [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: So maybe just
tell us your name first.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Pascal.
First of all, thanks
for the great talk.
It was very interesting.
Many great thoughts I
could take away from it.
And I wanted to ask, because
you addressed adversity
that we face-- for years I
self-described as a feminist
as well, thinking very much
like you presented that it's
all about creating a
future in which gender
does not have an influence
and who you are allowed to be.
But I dropped that
label a couple of years
ago because I faced adversity
from certain elements
within that group, specifically
transphobic elements
that you sometimes
encounter, where
it's all about like
situations and events
that are only for
women born as women.
And I wanted to ask, have
you encountered this?
And how did you address
this, if you did?
AILBHE SMYTH: Yes, it's
a very good question.
First of all, feminism is a
house of very many mansions
right across the world.
And there are, of course,
a whole host of attitudes.
And the one you describe is
not one that I share at all.
I could just speak from
the very early experience
of organizing Lesbian
Lives in UCD, back
in the very early 1990s, where
there was a challenge when
a transwoman was in a workshop
and was asked to leave.
And I was extremely
upset and angry about it.
And we immediately went
to set up, actually,
a meeting with
transpeople in Dublin.
I think that was in 1993.
It was a very, very,
very long time ago.
And after that, Lesbian
Lives-- I'm just
giving this as one example--
was absolutely open.
And the only workshop that men
who identified as men could not
attend was the
workshop on violence,
on interlesbian violence
because it does occur.
And it was felt that for
the safety and security
of the participants this would
definitely be a woman only.
but open to transwomen.
So I feel very strongly
that there should not
be closed doors.
I feel very strongly that we
should be doing everything
in our power to move--
and I love being lesbian--
but to move beyond
those straitjackets that
gender imposes, really on all of
us, whether we are aware of it
or not.
So I hope that responds a
little bit to your question.
And keep going.
Keep standing up
for yourself there.
And let's hope that
we can, together, make
that more gender-free world.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: We've time
for one more question.
Nobody?
OK, I think we might
finish up there then.
And thanks very much
to the panel for today
and especially to Ailbhe
for our keynote speech.
Have a great weekend.
Happy pride!
AILBHE SMYTH: Happy pride!